hemos tenido la entrega de medallas en
seis deportes pero con un gran
protagonista que es el boxeo es noche de
boxeo en valledupar la velada ha estado
cubriendo a nuestro enviado especial
luis méndez louis la noche que comenzó
con victoria para un verdadero héroe
local
y así como lo dice juan un verdadero
héroe que atrajo a decenas de fanáticos
de este deporte muy seguido en esta zona
de colombia en la ciudad de valledupar y
que por supuesto rindió con una nueva
medalla giubergia y martínez se quedó
con la dorada en el peso mosca al vencer
al venezolano miguel ramos por puntos
una decisión unánime en tres asaltos
pegó los mejores golpes y se vio
sumamente confiado a lo largo de su
combate el ganador de la medalla de
plata en río 2016 pero hay que señalar
que este peleador ya está próximo a dar
su salto al boxeo profesional y también
conversó con nosotros y con todos los
medios sobre sus ambiciones y sus
aspiraciones después de dar ese salto
escuchemos yo pienso que este puesto lo
estamos tomando como una pre competencia
para lo que se viene que es el debut de
llevar el mar tiene como deseado
profesional y nada esto nos sirve de
preparación tengo dos sueños que son muy
grandes muchas personas me dirán que soy
ambicioso pero si soy ambicioso y me
gusta soñar en grande yo sé que los
sueños se cumplen pero hay que trabajar
por eso lo que venimos haciendo
trabajando para hacer realidad cada uno
de estos sueños que tanto es el campeón
mundial de consejo profesional como ser
medallista de oro en unos juegos
olímpicos
[Música]
la velada en lo que va de noche ha sido
positiva para colombia porque también
consiguió la medalla dorada en el peso
pluma por intermedio de jean marc
gonzález el dominicano alexis de la cruz
se quedó con la dorada en el peso ligero
al tiempo que el venezolano cristian
palacio se hizo con el máximo honor en
el peso welter mientras tanto hay que
señalar que el dominicano en ring sede
no cargo con los honores en el peso
medio